-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
I'm here with Kirk and Tariq
from The Roots.
And we're about to play a game
called "Musical Beers."
But, first, we're gonna need
a few more players.
He is the host of
"Celebrity Beef,"
airing Tuesdays at 10:00 p.m.
on E!
Give it up for Joel McHale!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Joel, back here.
No, Joel, come back.
Joel, come back here.
Come back. No, no.
They're not --
Joel, thank you very much.
Stay there. There he goes.
No, no. Stay here.
Plus, she stars in
the new movie "Not Okay,"
which is streaming now on Hulu.
Please welcome Zoey Deutch!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Now, the game works like
musical chairs,
but instead of diving into
empty chairs,
we're going to be grabbing
these red cups of beer.
When the music stops, one person
will be left empty-handed.
They are out of the game
and have to hangout with our
DJ up there, DJ Sam the Butcher.
We're going to do four rounds.
The last one standing is
the "Musical Beers" champion.
Everyone, space yourselves out.
Let's get ready.
When the music stops, that's
when you have to grab your beer.
-Is it a bad time to mention
that I'm an alcoholic?
-That's good, Joel.
No, that's why we
put you in this game.
-Okay. Thank you.
♪♪
I'm jonesing.
-You can move back
a little bit, Zoey.
[ Music slowing ]
[ Music intensifies, slows ]
♪♪
[ Music stops ]
-Oh, no.
You take it.
-Well, this one --
-No, no, no. I could never.
I am the host. I could never.
Please just drink that
arm beer and...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Alright, now there
are three beers on there.
Higgins, good job.
-Oh, really?
-Zoey, do it for us.
Come on, bud.
Joel, good luck. Whoa.
Be careful!
You never know, Kirk.
You're too competitive, buddy.
Oh, my God.
Tariq, do not touch that.
Whoa!
[ Music stops ]
It did stop. It stopped! Yes!
-What?!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Go, Joel!
Kirk, come up here with me.
-Damn.
-Yeah, come on, Kirk.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I ain't going out
like that again.
-[ Laughs ]
-Whoo!
Oh, my gosh.
-I'm pretty drunk now.
-Alright, Joel, the garbage can
is in the middle,
not our stage.
Thank you very much.
Okay, here we go.
♪♪
It's going faster now.
Here we go.
Good luck, everybody.
Tariq's been practicing.
Oh, my God.
[ Music slows ]
No. It's not stopped.
Keep going. Keep going.
It didn't stop!
It's just slow.
He's messing with your mind.
[ Music stops ]
Oh!
Wow!
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-[ Groans ]
-That's all right.
We'll take care of you.
-Aah!
-Alright, the last cup
has been placed.
It's Zoey versus Tariq
for the champ, "Musical Beers."
Zoey, you know
who I'm rooting for.
[ Cheers and applause ]
DJ Fievel goes West,
let's do it.
[ Slow carnival music playing ]
-This is terrifying music.
-Yeah, why does it
have to be so spooky?
-He plays birthday parties,
bar mitzvahs.
Whatever you need, he's there.
-It's haunting.
-Oh, my God. Take it seriously!
-Take beer
musical chairs seriously!
[ Music intensifies ]
-Aah! Aah! Aah! Aah!
[ Music slows ]
-Oh, my God.
Tariq, you can't just
stand there.
-I'm scared! I'm afraid!
[ Music stops ]
Aah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The winner!
-It's really you.
You have to finish this.
[ Dinging ]
♪♪
I don't know, but was that fair?
'Cause you really --
-Yes. Come on, bud.
Our thanks to Joel McHale,
Zoey Deutch, the champ!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're talking to Joel McHale
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back.
Of course that's fair.
-I don't know.